My small improvement seed with avoiding my red zone foods for my food allergy test. So think this
person did the Syrex 10 has reversed. So I'm back to no regular bowel movements. And I managed to
get a cold. I'd never get sick. I've noticed that in the past that if I do a restrictive diet of
any sort or detox all veggie diet, I tend to get sick. Any thoughts on adjustments to make? I'm still
not getting any less noticeable bloating. My 10 or so foods are high carb, high histamine, etc., but
all in the green zone. And watching a gut course by Stephen Wright, his main point seems to be the old
formula of gut powders, zinc cardicine, glutamine, etc., are outdated. Seems he's recommending really
increasing the butyrate. For example, his supplement sells 500 milligrams. So understand what butyrate is.
Butyrate is calcium and magnesium butyrate is butyric acid. Butyric acid is made in the gut
by ameto acids. And from ameto acids, your gut makes butyric acid. And that is the main fuel source
for your endothelial cells. So yeah, that's why I highly recommend taking butyrate as a gut healer,
gut support. Butyrate also can help calm down what I mentioned in that other person's question is
SIBO, if the person has small intestine or bacterial overgrowth, which how do you get small intestine
bacterial overgrowth? Well, you get the most common thing is taking any sorts of medications that
throws off of your, throws off your gut microbiota. You could get your the microbiota that is
limited, your larger intestine that didn't get killed off overgrow into the smaller intestine. That's
what's small intestine bacteria overgrowth is. One way you know you have it, I mean, you could do a
test for a GI panel will test for SIBO. There's specific SIBO tests that test for different
gases in a breath test as well. But one way you could have a big clue that you know you have SIBO is
if fiber makes you worse. So if taking like a fiber supplement makes you worse, then it's pretty
much guaranteed you have SIBO. And the treatment for SIBO, the SIBO protocol really is to go off
of all fiber and to go on butyrate for a period of time. And it doesn't take that long to get that back
into balance. But I would disagree with Steven right, that the gut formulas are outdated. All those
things that we discussed that like zinc, uh, caracid, uh, cardacene and glutamate and slippery
album and yellow and all those things are healing to the gut. It's just because you know using butyrate
is the latest and greatest because understand so a little bit of history butyrate wasn't a supplement
until, um, fairly recently. And butyrate is made by your gut, um, through, um, uh, breakdown of food.
And when butyrate came out as a supplement, then it was the latest and greatest thing. But it didn't,
it didn't like, you know, uh, substitute for other gut healing herbs and things. Um, it's just another
thing to use to help get your gut in balance. I would highly suggest using it. And if you're looking
for a substitute for the, the, the supplement, he says try to look at the designs for help try
butyrate, uh, try butyrate and slippery. I think it is, it's three different forms of butyrate.
I thought it couldn't hurt to get laser focused in full while I'm dealing with this problem. Absolutely.
You can get as much information as you possibly can in there.